And this is going to be a
discussion of the blood and
blood transfusions,
specifically the ABO groups, the
RH system and disease and
transfusion medicine in general.
I'm here in Arkansas. If
you're here, you can come
to my office from 424F or
give me a call or email me.
These are the objectives.
So with transfusion
medicine, understanding
the immunologic basis
of transfusions is
important. So we'll go
over some aspects of that,
and also understanding
the AVORH systems.
We'll learn something about
the different components
of whole blood and the
indications for their use,
understand appropriate
transfusion practices
and know the alternatives
to transfusion,
different types of
reactions and how to manage
them and evaluate them,
and understand the
different transmitted
diseases that may occur.
Okay, blood has a form
of element component,
for example RBCs,
WBCs, that's about
40% and this diagram
shows you that.
They contain antigens, so
that's important to understand
with the immunology of
transfusion and then
plasma that contains antigens
and antibodies in them.
So that's another part that
is important to understand.
so humans belong to
different blood groups
different components we're
talking about transfusion
we aren't usually talking
about our red blood
cell transfusions but
for example platelets
and other clothes can
have different antigens
on them that need to be
addressed occasionally
so with the transfusion
the immune system of
the recipient is going
to react with antigens
that are different
from itself and form
antibodies against those
antigens that they lack.
So to perform that
procedure safely,
the antigens have to match
the patient's blood type.
And I just list some
potential complications
that can occur, and we'll
discuss some of that
as we go along. And
some of them can be life
-threatening. Although
because of the testing
that's done and the
proper selection and use,
many of these conditions
are rare due to
transfusions which is
the whole purpose of
discovering how transfusions
work and testing them
so antibodies and
transfusions there's just two
different groups generally
of antibodies there's
natural ones and immune type
antibodies natural means
that person was never
exposed to a transfusion an
injection or pregnancy
and so they were just
formed naturally by some
process in the body most of
those are what's called
cold reacting antibodies
and that means they react
best at room temperature
which means below body
temperature and those are
commonly IgM type and
important remember that they
IgMs are a real good
activating complement.
Most commonly,
these antibodies are
formed against the
ABO, also called
ABH antigens, and
we'll discuss that,
how ABH is the same
thing as ABO. So they're
usually clinically
significant when they're
active at 37 degrees
or body temperature.
And that's because those
ones can produce rapid
intravascular hemolysis.
Because remember, those IgMs,
which are normally cold
reactive, they're 37 reactive.
An ABO system is an exception
to IgMs that are active
at body temperature. They
can activate complement
and cause lysis of those
cells within the blood system,
within the vascular system.
Immune cells, immune
antibodies require a person
to have been exposed before,
and there's going to be
a first exposure, second
exposure effect that we'll
learn about in a little bit.
Those are going to be mostly
warm reacting antibodies,
which means they'll react
best at body temperature.
It's commonly going to
be of the IgG type, And
the most common ones of
interest and clinical
significance are anti-RH
antibodies, but also anti-CAL,
WKID. There's a whole
lot of different antigens
on red blood cells and the
antibodies against them.
They can be hemolytic,
and that's usually going
to be what's called
extravascular versus
intravascular loss, which
means they're going to
opsonize, for example,
red blood cells. Those red
cells are going to travel
to the spleen or liver
where the macrophages
will remove those from
circulation. So that's
extravascular hematosis.
And in order to detect
those and want to
understand why, the anti
-human globulin called
Kuhn's reagent is used
for detecting those.
So cold and warm reacting
antibodies, we'll
see the cold reacting
antibodies, IgM here.
They fail to undergo
class switching.
the IgG antibodies,
the primary exposure is
going to produce, you
know, a response, but it
won't be as large as
the secondary exposure.
Those are going to be B
cells that have become
B cells, the memory B
cells with a high affinity
and produce a high titer
of IgG on the second
exposure. The first
exposure won't be as high
as the second exposure
or as a high affinity.
Once the antigen stimulation
is removed, here's
the stimulation, it will
be days to weeks until
that antibody will be
reduced to a lower level,
essentially undetectable
by clinical means.
Okay,
so those antibodies
will usually become
undetectable. A major
exception is the ADO blood
group system because
it's naturally occurring.
And the reason that it's
clinically significant is
it best interacts with its
antigens at body temperature
and has a fantastic ability
to fix complement to
cell surfaces and cause
activation of the complement
system and the membrane
attack complex and destroy
cells. So that can produce
acute, immediate, hemolytic
transfusion reactions.
And why is the ABO there?
It's thought that the ABO
antibodies are thought to be
derived from the constant
stimulation from features
that are similar to
those antigens within the
environment. For example,
pollen grains, bacteria are
thought to provide that
constant antigenic stimulation.
And so those
antibodies are already
preformed in your circulation.
And they're there without
any prior exposure. And
it's just because you're
constantly exposed to all
these things that are
either like A or B antigens.
And so you will make
antibodies against those.
So most cold antibodies
are clinical and
submittal. I'll already
explain why. But
the major exception
is the ABO blood
resistance, for the
reasons I just explained.
Warm antibodies usually
are associated with
delayed hemolytic
transfusion reactions,
and while the delayed
reaction, one may
think, is not as
clinically significant
because you get
extravascular hermolysis,
is critically important
in a condition called
hemolytic disease of
the fetus and newborn,
or HDFN, also called
erythroblastosis vitalis.
Okay, major properties
of antibodies
in humans, you
see in this chart,
IgM has
five antibodies
that are bound together.
Each of those antibodies have
two antigen binding sites
for each of those five
antibodies, so it's a large
molecule that can span red
cells in circulation. IgG
is smaller, it only has two
antigen binding sites, but
it's the growth, it's the vast
majority of antibody within
a person's circulation.
Again, IgM is really
great at activating
complement, but IgG
also can do that.
So there are some acute
hemolytic transfusion
reactions that can
occur with IgG, although
those are rare.
And significantly,
IgG can cross the
placenta. Okay, so that
brings in the importance
of HDFN that we
just talked about.
IgE antibodies are able
to bind the mast cells and
vasophils, so involved
with type 1 type reactions.
And that's that.
So as I said, antibodies
capable of binding complement
ABO is mostly associated
with that. You see,
there's many others. These
ones will be rare cold
antibodies that will be
detected in certain individuals.
Also,
the deantigen, which is
IgG, but it is capable
of binding complement,
as we just saw in that
chart. But these are
going to be rare that that
will occur and cause
intravascular hemolysis.
And here's just a diagram
that goes over the
complement cascade.
Well, we're going to be,
there's three different
main systems of the main
pathways of the complement
system. That would
be the classical, the
lectin, the alternative.
But we'll be dealing,
when we talk about
transfusion medicine,
with the antibody
-dependent antigen-antibody
complex activation.
So that will be the
classical system
when it comes to transfusions.
Here's just a diagram of
some of the common RBC
antigens, you have the ABO,
which is H is a component
of that, but there's
also many other RH, you
can see these different
antigens, the extracellular
regions have many
different epitopes, and so
they're going to be
different antibodies that are
produced against each of
these different epitopes,
so that's why there's
over 40 different epitopes
that comprise the Rh
system. It just happened
that the big D antigen was
the first one detected.
The most important
red cell blood group
system for transfusion
are going to be the Rh
and the ABO. They
determine your blood type
so that you can receive
a safe transfusion.
Rh form as direct
gene products.
RBC endogens are carbohydrates,
I mean ABO endogens are
carbohydrates, and they're
created indirectly by the
gene producing enzymes, which
transfers carbohydrates to
form complex carbohydrates.
Those enzymes are glycosyl
transferases, and they'll
add carbohydrates to a
basic precursor substance,
oligosaccharide called
paragloboside. So the
H gene transfers a
terminal fucose to this
paraglobocyte, and
that makes H substance.
The O gene is an amorph.
It doesn't produce
an active enzyme.
So the H remains
unmodified, and that's
what the type O is.
It's just a
modified H precursor
without A or B
antigens on them.
Okay.
So, as I said, ABL-RH,
repeating, determine a
person's blood type or
group, and the clinical
significance is in
transfusion reaction, most
importantly, is due to
immediate, acute, or delayed
hemolytic transfusion
reactions that also lead
to hemolytic disease of
the fetus and newborn.
ABO is associated with
immediate transfusion reactions
due to an incompatible
blood type. Usually today,
that's most commonly due
to human error, although
that's very rare that these
reactions occur because of
the regulation and the
testing that is outperformed.
So almost immediate rapid
intravascular hemolysis
of donor RBCs.
Other RBCs are the
unexpected immune type.
You don't expect them
to be there. They're
required by alloimmunization,
that means prior
sensitization to RBC
antigens. The most
significant ones are
RH, and I list the ones,
D, Big D, Big C, Little
C, Big E, Little E,
and Cal, a couple
different types, that
are most significant
antigens when it's immune
type of antibodies,
usually associated
with delayed and
extravascular hemolysis.
And here's a diagram
that just shows how these
antigens are formed of the
ABO system. O will have this
terminal fucose here added
to the paragloboside and
that will produce your H
precursor or H substance.
If you add an acetyl
galactosamine to that, then
you get the A type, if you
add galactose to that you
get the B type, if you
add both then you get AB.
The different antibodies
you can see produce
different antigen
antibodies that are produced
worldwide make blood type
O the most common blood
type worldwide, then
A, then B, and then AB.
There's a phenotype known
as Bombay phenotype which
is rare and is due to
the lack of the antigen.
But these folks also
naturally produce naturally
occurring anti-A, anti-B,
and anti-H. And all of these
can produce intravascular
molysis. So it's a
problem to transfuse these
persons because essentially
everybody else has that H
substance except for this
phenotype. They can only
get blood from another
person with that phenotype.
So that's a difficulty
transfusion red blood cell
ABO system and IgM antibodies
I said that they are
large and red cells in
circulation are repelled repel
each other due to an ionic
cloud that's around them
I got another diagram that
shows you that but the
IgM antibody is very large
and it has five different
antibodies that are attached
with two different antigen
binding sites and it can
span these red cells and
cause agglutination in testing
also known as hemagglutination
but also with an
incompatible transfusion it
also can produce that and
activation complement the
lysis of those cells so
you see visual clumping and
testing systems as part of
blood typing there's in
order to determine a person's
ABO type there's a forward
grouping and reverse
grouping so with forward
grouping that detects the
patient's RBC sample so
you're looking what's for what
ABO antigen they have in a
sample of their red blood
cells and use reagents anti
-A anti-B antibodies and
that's a test done at room
temperature since that's
where the antibodies attach
best at room temperature
since they're cold but they
can attach at 37 with the
ABL system, and then you
check for hemagglutination.
In the reverse grouping,
that serves as confirmation
of the forward grouping
results, so the patient's
antibodies are added to
reagent A cells and B cells,
and once again, it tests
that immediate spin,
which means centrifuge at
room temperature, and look
for hemagglutination, and
it helps you determine their
ABL group. There's also
another antibody test you
can use to determine the
RH type, that's anti-D,
and it's usually a mixture
of anti-D, IgM, and IgG.
Okay, and here's that ionic
cloud I was talking about
when it comes to IgG and
IgM and its relevance to
hemagglutination. And you
see the cells are held apart
approximately 25 nanometers
due to the ionic cloud.
And IgG is 14 nanometers
from tip to tip
of the antibody
binding sites, antigen
binding sites, so
not quite big enough.
But IgM is about 35 nanometers
and can span this distance.
So researchers discovered
what's known as the anti
-human globulin reagent,
also known as AHG or
Coombs reagents, and
that's used in the direct
antibody test to detect
IgG or C3 attached to a
patient's red cells. Why
C3? Because sometimes IgM
binds and then it takes
complement to the surface.
But when the tests
are done and you're
looking for warm
reacting antibodies,
that IgM might come
off. But the C3 would
still be attached,
so you can detect it.
But that acts as a bridge
to sensitized cells.
So cells that have IgG
attached to them, you
can add AHG, which
will bind to those
antibodies. And that's a
direct antiglobulin test.
And these help
detect that IgG is
attached to those
cells. And you do the
test and look for
hemoglutination.
Then there's the indirect
antiglobulin test, which
incubates the patient's
serum, their IgG antibodies.
So you're seeing if they
will have those antibodies
in their serum that could
be causing a problem.
And you use reagent
screening cells to detect
if there's antibodies
to the common antigens
that would produce
transfusion reactions.
And this is a diagram
that shows how,
diagrammatically,
the indirect and
direct antiglobulin
tests would work.
So with direct antiglobulin,
you want to see
what antibodies attach
to the cells already.
and then you add your Kim's
reagents, which is going
to detect these antibodies,
and you look for clumping.
And I circled this area
right here because these
are the same steps with
the direct and then the
indirect antihumine covenate
test. The only difference
is you take reagent
cells, those are cells
that the lab has, and
then you add the patient's
serum and then you incubate.
So you warm it for a
certain period of time,
usually about a half hour
and then, well, 50
minutes to a half hour and
then the cells will
be sensitized. So then
you can start here
and you're basically
performing this test right
there and looking for
clumping and that's
how the two tests work.
The DAT is, and both are
used for the clinical workup
of hemolytic transfusion
reactions and HDFN And I
already explained what the
DAT is detecting, and you're
looking for IgG C3 on the
surface of RBCs. And IAT,
you're looking at the
patient's serum for antibodies,
okay?
IAT is also part of the
antibody screen, which is
going to be part of the
type and screen. So I just
mentioned how you check
blood type, but with the
screen, you can check
the patient's to see if
there's any unexpected
antibodies against a panel of
screening red blood cells
that has the most common
antigens on them, and
that would be the screen.
You'd see if there's
antibodies there.
A major cross-match,
and so type and screen
is important to do if
there's any kind of
procedure that you think
they may need blood.
But there's another test
called the cross-match or
type and cross. So, type and
cross involves figuring out
the blood type, but then
also you've got to do the
cross match or the major
cross match, which is testing
of the donor's red blood
cells against the recipient
serum. And that's necessary
for all transfusions to
make sure that if you detect,
if you do the immediate
spin test, that'll detect
ABO incompatibility only.
But the major cross-match
involves an incubation stage
at 37 degrees C to check
for significant unexpected
IgG antibodies, and then
you use antiglobulin phase
after incubation, and that's
your major cross-match,
and that'll take about an
hour to perform that test.
Significantly, if you type
and cross for, say, like
five units of blood, because
you're thinking they might
need five units of blood,
that removes that blood
from the inventory. It can't
be used for anybody else,
and it's sent down to,
you know, for the patient.
And once it's gone from
the blood bank, there's no
guarantees on how that blood
was maintained or stored or
anything. So getting that
blood back to use for others
is probably not going to be
done by the blood bank. So
that removes that blood
from inventory, essentially.
So if you think they might need
blood, type and
screen is important,
and that can be
converted quite rapidly
to blood that can
be made available
to you by a couple
different means okay
well forget where I
was here I I stopped
recording this for a
second but okay I think
I was was here to
restart it here Okay,
after the ABO system,
the RH system is most
important to determine
your blood type for
safe transfusion.
And the RH system is
the most frequent target
of allo antibodies
caused by transfusions or
multiferous females
that can become allo and
immunized to fetal
antigens and lead to HDFM.
The first RH antigen to
find was the D-antigen.
and the term positive
and negative refers to
whether that big D antigen
is there or not. So
with someone's type O
in the ABO blood group
system, their positive and
negative status determines
whether they are D
positive or D negative.
There are more than 40
different antigens on the
RH blood group system,
And the most common RH
antigens routinely tested
for are identified, are
listed here, with D being
the most immunogenic.
That leads us to
HDFN, also known as
Ibertheroblastosis vitalis,
and the role of RH immune
globulin. And what RH
immune globulin is,
is an anti-D antibody
that's given to mothers
to help prevent HDFN,
also known as RHIG.
So how does HDFN occur?
First,
the mother is Rh
negative, baby is
Rh positive. Some
of their blood,
baby's blood might
leak into the mother's
circulation across
the placenta, and that
could cause the mother
to form antibodies. This
first exposure is
going to produce, well,
some IgG antibody, but
not the high titers you
get on second exposure,
and it won't be as
high affinity as second
exposure. So the mom's
already formed the
antibody on first exposure.
And so she's Rh negative.
If she has another Rh
positive fetus, then you'll
get the second response,
which will be high titer,
high affinity antibodies,
which will cross the
placenta and cause lysis
of the fetus's red blood
cells and produce HTFM.
If the mother's given Rh Ig at
certain points
during her pregnancy,
then any red cells
that leak across the
placenta The RHIG binds
to those and inactivates
them, so the mom doesn't
form an antibody.
Transfusion reactions,
generally overall, have a
very low incidence, about
1%. And the most common
ones are very low themselves,
like the allergic-type
reaction and BFAR reactions
are the most common.
And then something called
TACO we'll discuss, and
then the delayed hemo-related
transfusion reactions.
Then there's septic reactions
from contamination
with bacteria.
There's something called
trolley, which we'll
talk about, anaphylaxis.
Then the acute or
immediate type reactions
are very rare, and that's
because of all the
testing and regulation
of transfusion that
occurs in the blood bank.
If we didn't do
all the testing and
have all the
regulations, there would
be a lot more injuries
to individuals.
Transfusion-associated
graft-versus-host
disease is the last one,
and we'll discuss that
too. There are some
overlapping signs and
symptoms, and this could
lead to misdiagnoses.
Okay.
Delayed or extravascular
and acute hemolytic
transfusion reactions,
or intravascular.
This chart here shows
the signs and symptoms
that you might find
and some of the
treatments that you
might be expected to do.
With a delayed type,
hemolytic transfusion
reaction often involves
a RH system. What you'll
see clinically is a low
hemoglobin, increased
bilirubin, and a new
antibody on testing.
For example, when
you do the DAT.
The most common cause
of acute hemolytic
transfusion reaction
is ABO incompatibility.
That's most commonly due
to human error, although
it's very rare today.
As I said before,
some IgG antibodies
may fix complement,
like KID, RH, Cal, Duffy,
and they may produce
an acute reaction,
but it's very rare.
With delayed reactions,
it's going to be delayed,
so it's going to be days
after the transfusion.
Life-threatening
complications are
going to be rare,
and the signs and
symptoms and acute is
going to be abrupt.
Sign of symptoms do overlap.
You will have anemia and
fever, maybe some jaundice,
but you'll get acute
intravascular hemolysis
producing hypotension, fever,
acute kidney injury, DIC,
and other clinical signs
and symptoms that are
very much more severe.
The delayed reactions are
rarely life-threatening.
Acute reactions, you have
to stop the transfusion
because they could
be fatal and send the
blood and the any unused
blood and the infusion
kit back to the blood
bank for analysis.
For delayed reactions,
you would want to confirm
the type and screen and
detect the now anybody,
so that you can give
that patient that antigen
negative blood in case
they need it again later.
And for the current therapy,
you would be supportive.
For the acute reactions,
your treatment
would be supportive.
We would support the
blood pressure with
IV fluids, pressors,
and their kidney
function with diuresis.
And so I listed out here,
you stop the transfusion,
maintain pressure, airway,
and return the equipment
to the lab, check the
peripheral blood for
schistocytes and brown serum,
see if there's increased
LDH due to lysis to the
red cells, check their
bilirubin, look for jaundice,
check the haptoglobin
level, check for hemoglobin
area, hemoglobinemia,
and monitor renal function
with BUN, creatinine,
and repeat the cross
-matching and the DAT-IAT.
Feveral hemolytic transfusion
reactions are due to
cytokines released during
component storage or antibodies
in a patient's plasma to
donor leukocytes or platelets
okay it's more commonly
in multiply transfused
patients who may have
developed these antibodies to
leukocytes and platelets or
multiple women who may have
been exposed to those
antigens through the pregnancy
process what you'll see is
fever sometimes chills and
nausea sometimes but without
evidence of homolysis
or allergic reactions and
this type of reaction is
usually more uncomfortable than
it is serious so antipyretics
could be given stop the
transfusion and monitor
for progress progression
and possibly consider
restarting the transfusion if
it's necessary for the patient
allergic transfusion
reactions are caused by
antibodies from prior exposure
to donor plasma proteins.
The most common, obviously,
is with plasma-rich components
like platelets or FFP.
What you see are immediate
manifestations, urticaria
is common, but also
bronchospasm can present
initially, or anaphylaxis. Any
difficulty breathing symptoms
require rapid treatment.
So stop the transfusion,
monitor for progress,
get antihistamines,
possibly oxygen,
hydrochlorisone,
epinephrine, and anaphylaxis.
Transfusion associated
circulatory overload is what
TACO is and you can see
this circulatory overload in
this x-ray here with blunted
costalphrenic angles and
alveolar pulmonary edema
and infiltrates within the
lung fields and it's also
it's cardiogenic pulmonary
edema due to volume overload.
So it's hyperbolemia.
So you'll see the signs
symptoms of that. Dyspnea,
hypoxemia,
tachycardia, crackles.
And why does it occur?
Because a person might have
some disease that increases
their blood volume. That
includes liver, heart, or
kidney problem failure, or
if they're receiving many
transfusions. So it's
managed similar to congestive
heart failure, where you
would stop the transfusion,
oxygen, diuretics, and slow
or limit the transfusions.
And sometimes that talk
goes confused with TRALI,
transfusion related, a cheap
lung injury. And the reason
this occurs is because
the previous transfusion
or transplantation in a
donor, so the blood product
is actually causing, has the
antibodies that are causing
this problem. The donor
may become sensitized
because of that to neutrophil
antibodies. So a person
who has a pre-existing
pulmonary pathology that causes
neutrophils to accumulate
in their mycovascular
and then is added antineutrophil
antibodies reacts to
those and will produce this
edema within the lungs.
And signs of symptoms
of acute respiratory
distress, tachypnea,
dyspnea, hypotension.
So treatment is supportive.
and typically comes from
products containing a
lot of plasma, you know,
where the antibodies are.
And one method of reducing
the risk in people for
TRALI is that multiple
female donors' products which
have a lot of plasma are
not used for patients
who might be at risk for
the development of TRALI.
Transfusion-associated
graft-versus-host disease
occurs because donor T
lymphocytes are normally
removed from the recipient
circulation by an intact
recipient immune system.
However, if they're
immuno-incompetent,
then their donor T cells
can engraft and attack
the host. And what you'll
see is pancytopenia and
multi-organ failure,
commonly skin, liver,
and gut manifestations.
It's usually fatal,
so you want to prevent
it, and that's prevented
by gamma irradiation
which inactivates those
donor T lymphocytes.
It's usually fatal in greater
than 90% of the cases.
Okay,
so you want to irradiate those
products for any
immunocompetent
persons and that could
be the very young,
less than six months,
or the very old or
someone with a disorder
of the immune system.
Bacterial contamination
also known as septic
transfusion reaction has
a higher incidence with
certain blood products and
one of the blood products
higher incidence is with
platelets and that's
because those are stored
at room temperature
more than red blood cells
which are refrigerated.
With red cells, though,
there are incidences
and gram-negative
bacteria have contaminated
red cell products. I list
a couple of examples.
With platelets, gram
-positive organisms have been
found in septic transfusion
reaction with platelets.
And what you'll see is
fever, rigors, hypotension in
the form of septic shot and
potentially death. So you
have to stop transfusion,
antibiotics, and culture.
Make sure you tailor the
antibiotics for the organism.
We start with broad
spectrum antibiotics first.
Blood product collection and
transfusion is
heavily regulated.
FDA,
Medicare, Medicaid
Services, AABB, College
of American Pathologists,
those are the primary
regulatory bodies,
and there are others.
But a lot of regulations.
So to be a donor, there's
many different criteria,
but generally they have to
be in good health and feel
well, these 17 in most
days, certain weight. They
can't have donated recently,
so their body has had the
chance to replenish their
red cells or their platelets
or plasma or whatever
products they've donated.
And you're generally
temporarily excluded.
If you've had recent
infection, fever,
traveled to an endemic
disease area, certain drugs
that would be geratogen
potentially illicit
drug use unsafe ******
practices things like that
transfusion transmitted
diseases are very rare and
on the right column here
I list the incidences
that you know these these
disorders this diseases
have the incidences of
transfusion transmitted
diseases incidences are
listed over on the right side
okay and those I put these
ones here because that
compares to this donor screening
tests that are required
for all donors donor
products that'd be hepatitis
B and you would check for
all these different tests
hepatitis C HIV, HDLB,
********, West Smyl, Chagas,
Babesia, and Zika
virus, and that has made
transfusion very safe,
but it is a moving target
because of outbreaks and
other kinds of conditions.
It's constantly evolving,
and if not detected,
then the blood products
can cause harm since
they're used so frequently
on very ill people.
so one of the uh principles
of transfusion medicine
is a component therapy so
whole blood isn't used uh
as much as it used to be
in in the past it's now
used mostly for you know
trauma situations where a lot
of massive transfusions
are going to be occurring
but what is commonly done
is different components
are used for specific
conditions so whole blood is
centrifuged and that'll pack
your cells down and then
you can get your plasma
out of that and then you
get your pack cells and
you make you can use those
for transfusion you
centrifuge this again you get
your platelets at 20 degrees
C then you get a platelet
-poor plasma you freeze
it at minus 20 you'll get
fresh frozen plasma which
has a lot of the coagulation
factors and other of
plasma proteins and you
freeze it again at minus
70 and then thaw and then
cryoprecipitate is produced
and these different we'll
talk about how the different
components can be used
so first here's a centrifuge
used to centrifuge the
whole blood and then one
of these bags contain about
500 milliliters there's
nancy coagulant called
citrate which chelates calcium
So, if a person has, and
it's normally, citrate is
normally metabolized by
liver, so if someone has
liver problems, you know,
maybe toxicity might become
an issue, or if it's a
********* infant or
something like that, that may
become an issue. So, it
has to be monitored for
hypocalcemia if a lot of the
product is going to be used.
So, these whole blood
products are going to be
refrigerated, and I already
mentioned about mass
transfusions, that they
still have used today. The
flasmin and platenus can
be removed as components.
Pac-Bread cells, Pac-DRVCs
are, after they're mixed
with citrate, they can be
used just like that. But
that shelf life refrigerated
is up to 35 days. If
they mix with an additive
like AdSol, that's a
lower volume, but the storage
life is extended to 42
days. And those products
are refrigerated as well.
Leukocytes are considered
contaminants of cellular
components of products,
and they're considered
contaminants because
they can have adverse
consequences, usually
immunologically mediated.
Also infectious disease
transmission, and I list some
of the immunological
problems that can occur, and
also some of those cells,
the modern nuclear cells,
can contain dormant
viruses like
cytomyelovirus that
can be transmitted.
So there are filters
that have been developed
that remove leukocytes,
and I hear the arrow
showing where that filter
is, so it's in line
with the tubing coming
out of the bag, and And
those filters can
prevent CMV transmission,
alloimmunization
with HLA antibodies,
or feeble
non-hemolytic
transfusion reactions.
Leukocytes are though
rarely occasionally
transfused, although
they're difficult to get,
the benefits aren't entirely
clear. It's a high risk
of reaction. So the risk
may outweigh the benefits,
but an incase would be
a severely neutropenic
person or an infection
unresponsive to antibiotics.
So they have
helped some people.
In immunocompetent
patients, you want to make
sure that you gamma or
x-ray irradiate those
products to inactivate
contaminating T lymphocytes
to prevent transfusion
-associated graft
-versus-host disease.
Those indications include
low birth weight
infants, ********* immune
deficiencies,
hematologic malignancies,
bonus that are HLA mats,
or directed donations,
because those products
might not be seen as
foreign, and those T
lymphocytes may want it, may
engraft in a person
who's immuno-incompetent.
Okay.
So, if someone has recurrent
allergic transfusion reactions,
those platelets or red
cells, they can be washed
using isotonic saline
to remove the plasma
proteins that are causing
those types of reactions.
A major indication
for freezing red
cells is to collect
rare donor units,
maybe like the Bombay
phenotype units.
So, appropriate red cell
indications means that when
there's not an alternative
treatment available
or the clinical manifestations
demand treatment, then
that's when RBC transfusions
would be indicated.
For example, most patients,
current guidelines
generally are levels below
7 grams per deciliter.
the hemoglobin will,
they will be transfused.
Or if you have some
underlying disease where you
need oxygen-carrying capacity
that's not going to be
too low, for example,
coronary artery disease, you
might transfuse them at a
higher hemoglobin level.
And response to transfusion
does vary. One red cell
unit expects to increase
their hemoglobin by one
gram or deciliter, and
hematocrit by three percent
okay so alternative
transfusion of donor red cells
is trying to treat the
underlying condition for
example supplemental iron
folate vitamin b12 or
maybe erythropoietin or
there's autologous transfusion
which means you are
donating your blood to the
blood bank and they're
collecting it and then you
may re-infuse it back to
you so you can pre-deposit
self-transfusion you can
do acute normal volemic
hemodilution which means
blood is removed and then
fluid resuscitation is
performed uh chris floyd
college well whatever
uh the the doctor wants
to do and so that maintains
their blood volume
and then they're given
their red cells back
during our shortly
after procedure then
there's cell savers on
which uh salvage cells
that from the
procedure and then use
those for reinfusion
so surgical procedures
normally do not require
blood for transfusion however
I wrote the indication
for when people will have
transfusion or doctors will
estimate how much blood has
been lost by various means
and they may get want to give
them pack red cells and
with some crystalloid
resuscitation based on how much
blood volume has been lost.
So a typhine strain is
proven obtained if blood
products are anticipated
before any surgeries. Typhine
cross for surgical procedure
with the low likelihood
wastes time and resources.
We already discussed that.
Massive bleeding and massive
transfusion protocol, MTP.
Massive bleeding has
various definitions
and I just wrote
one of them here.
So, MTPs are a process
of management of blood
transfusion or major bleeding
episodes. There are locally
agreed specific guidelines
between the laboratory,
the clinician,
blood bank, and that
produces effective
logistics for responses.
And here's an example for
the protocol in obstetrics.
This protocol is
activated by clinicians
in response to severe
massive bleeding.
So balanced transfusions
are going to be
given, and here's what
that would mean, 1-1-1,
well,
6 units, 6 units, 6 units,
and 10 units of cryo.
And those are used
in an effort to avoid
dilutional coagulopathies
that may occur.
And usually after about 5
units of packed red cells,
The lab tests are rechecked
to determine whether
the person needs more
blood or still needs to
be on this massive transfusion
protocol, or whether
they may need something
like tranexamic acid,
which prevents blood clots
from becoming dissolved.
Platelet transfusions,
normally their lifespan
is 5 to 10 days, and
they're stored at room
temperature with general
agitation. Indications
are thrombocytopenia
or low platelet count,
less than 10,000
platelets per microliter,
and deep transfusion
to avoid a spontaneous
hemorrhage, less than
50,000 if there's one
bleeding or surgery that
is occurring, or less than
100,000 if there's CNS
bleeding or surgery.
There are two
clinically significant
but uncommon syndromes
that occur with
platelet alloantigen
sensitization.
Most commonly,
the platelet antigen that's
going to be affected is
going to be HPA-1A, so you
have an antibody, an anti-HPA
-1A antibody, and that'll
affect But there are two
different conditions, neonatal,
aluminium and thrombocytopenia,
there's placental transfer
of MOM's antibody,
they're affecting
neonatal platelets.
In the MOM, sometimes
there's post-transfusion
purpura and that's most often
in previously non-transfused
multiparous women who
have formless antibody.
Transfusion of plasma and
its derivatives, FFP is
used for the multiple
coagulation factor deficiencies,
best FFPs for fresh frozen
plasma, for example,
liver disease, DIC,
or a process called
plasma exchange, and rapid
reversal of warfarin.
Liquid plasma, which means
it's never been frozen,
is used for immediate
rapid transfusion in
some MTP protocols until
the FFP is done. Here's
some components that
you can get out of your
plasma products. Cryo
-precipitate is indicated
for these conditions, Von
Woolley-Brand, urenia,
DIC, and fibrinogen
deficiency because it
contains factor VIII,
fibrinogen, Von Woolley
-Brand factor, factor
XIII, and fibronectin.
Albumin.
The albumin maintains your
colloid oncotic pressure.
It's indicated, it doesn't
have a lot of implications,
but it does have some,
and it's indicated for
nephrotic syndrome that's
resistant to diuretics,
volume replacement in
plasmapheresis, and
large volume paracentesis,
if that's performed.
IVIG is paired by fractionation
of pools of human plasma.
It's indicated for immune
deficiency syndromes.
Hemophilia A, factor A
deficiency, hemophilia B,
factor IX deficiency, and
von Willibrand's disease are
shown here, and the products
that can be used from
plasma for those. There
is a recombinant factor
VIII for hemophilia A, that's
known as anti-hemophilic
factor, and that's
preferred, these recombinant
factors, over these plasma
-derived concentrates like
factor IX here, because
of the risk of infection.
But these are virally
attenuated products, so they're
made, tried to make it
safe as much as possible.
And then there's recombinant
factor VIIa, which
bypasses factor VIII and IX
and causes direct clotting.
So that's where people
have antibodies from, you
know, receiving multiple
doses of these products
and then form antibodies
against the other ones.
So you can switch to
Factor 7 if you need that.
DDAVP releases von Willibrand
factor from endothelial cells.
And crab precipitate
is rarely used
today because of
the viral risk.
QMAP is a mixture
of Factor 8 and von
Willibrand factor
because there are
complex in circulation
of people who are,
and von Willibrand stabilizes
Factor 8. So, many people
with von Oli-Brand disease
also have low levels of
factor A. So, Hume-A-P is a
desired product to be used.
And thank you.
Good luck with your studies.
Thank you for your time.
And send me some
feedback if you
want, or I'd appreciate that.
Okay. All the best. Bye.